[Musique]
la réouverture des lieux de culture je
veux que je veux croiser les doigts
la réouverture des lieux de culture on
l'at elle va arriver vite au printemps
alors on nous a annoncé le 21 mars m
vous voulez me faire dire des dates
résidence est pas facile par les temps
qui courent
le présidentielle et est remplacé par le
présentiel dans nos espoirs d'honneur
d'honneur d'honneur c'est comme dans la
série baron noir vous deveniez président
de la république quel serait votre
première mesure alors un voyage un
voyage à tout le monde un grand voyage à
tout le monde pour tous les français
dans le monde entier pour qu'ils voient
surtout en ce moment
voilà vraiment envoyé non mais oui bon
on va dire que ce poisson je serai pas
président de 1,6 à ces en 2022 au pire
en quoi êtes-vous le moins bon le moment
il la [ __ ] même projet j'aime beaucoup
marine le pen j'ai plein de points
communs avec elle
ah oui j'aime les chats oui et puis
c'est tout j'ai un petit rêve secret
j'aimerais me réincarner en chatte de
marine le pen alors pas pour qu'elle me
caresse
mais pour qu'elle ramasse mon cas car il
ya 750 mille personnes qui vivent de la
culture dans notre pays je passe ma vie
avec eux je les entends je les écoute je
les reçois chaque fois qu ils
m'interpellent benjamin biolay ma
m'interpelle là ce soir je le verrai
s'il le souhaite
vic tableau victoire de l'année volusien
quoi voulez dire et je suis allé me bat
mais je me bats je profite de la
présence ou de l'absence de madame la
ministre de l'absence peut-être
je précise je profite de sa présence ou
son absence pour ne rien réclamer garder
cette couverture du magazine society
joie de vivre
vu pour la dernière fois le 16 mars 2020
c'est assez malin c'est très malin même
qu au nom pas bien nick et en main
c'est camille thème louche au corona pas
bien nick exemple
neuf dans cette année de silence a suivi
un silence que j'ai trouvée à cette tour
descend un silence des pouvoirs publics
et des gens qui sont censés être nos
ministres de tutelle par exemple et
j'attend si c'est possible qu'on nous
écoute un petit peu parce que évidemment
on est des gens sérieux on ne ferait pas
n'importe quoi rien qu'en france les
chiffres sont frappants la fortune des
43 milliardaire français a progressé en
2020 et au même moment 8 millions de
français bénéficient de l'aide
alimentaire
ils étaient deux millions et demi deux
mois en temps normal les mois qui
viennent risquent d'aggraver la
situation
les trois vaccins fabriqués à partir des
reines messager sont les plus chers
jusqu'à près de 15 euros la dose de
vaccin moderna alors que le vaccin
d'astrazeneca à technologie
traditionnelle ne coûte qu'un euro 78 ça
ce sont les tarifs négociés par les pays
de l'union européenne
mais tout le monde ne paie pas le même
prix par exemple pour être servi
massivement et en premier israël a payé
deux fois plus cher ses doses pfizer la
part des vaccins qui ont été administrés
à des habitants des pays les plus
pauvres est dérisoire tellement
dérisoire qu'on a même du mal en citer
le chiffre faire des vaccins un bien
universel
il en a été question il n'en est plus
question non seulement les pays riches
pour l'instant égoïste mais c'est un
égoïsme mal compris parce que l'intérêt
bien compris des pays riches aujourd'hui
c'est de vacciner hommage à deux heures
de vol de mogadiscio
le somaliland vite en paix
nous nous rendons sans escorte cette
fois sans checkpoint dans cet état qui a
proclamé son indépendance en 1991
un pays fantôme mentionné sur aucune
carte officielle car il n'est pas
reconnu par la communauté internationale
[Musique]
oh
les européens ne connaissent pas encore
notre viande
mais ils vont se familiariser avec nous
exporterons vers l'europe
en plus l urine de chameau est un remède
naturel et peut soigner le coc vide
est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté des
diagrammes nom qu'on va de viagra et de
cialis l'autre c'est pas du viagra
oui pardon c'est efficace quand cette
fameuse petite pilule bleue va pardonner
la marque est sortie on nous avait
demandé à différentes personnalités à
l'époque de tester le cachet et bois
alors le problème c'est que j'aime
effectivement tester la petite pilule
mais je jure que c'est vrai la personne
que j'attendais n'est pas venu et je
vous jure que vous êtes fait que la
texture voyant ces images bas la
première c'est que la petite chemise sur
le téton la caf et ça c'était bien que
il est plutôt beau gosse alors je lui ai
donné un surnom à je l'appelle
maintenant jolitorax fou rire de tout
dans la mesure où on arrive à avoir de
l'autorité révision sur soi même déjà à
la baisse
70% des femmes célibataires cherchent
sur les applications de rencontre
l'amour durable
alors que 70% des hommes cherchent eux
je vous laisse deviner oui mais bien sûr
[Musique]
non
m
cette année
je paie
lapointe
la cheffe nina métayer donnent vie à ce
gâteau étonnant conçu comme un tableau
un baiser chocolatées points de kobe
donne envie de t'embrasser on a envie de
se faire des bisous et et on peut pas ça
mais on peut inspirer aussi pour une
idée du bisou c'est le visage qui vont
s'embrasser effet garanti auprès des
clients venus récupérer leur dessert cet
après midi en trop beau
[Musique]
ainsi toujours
mon ami
laurent wauquiez merci doit bien